-I want to talk about the
campaign, as well,
because, of course, it's ongoing
despite the fact that, you know,
a lot of primaries have been
canceled, rescheduled.
You've said you wanted to be
in the next debate.
How was the last debate?
I imagine it's
a little bit better
when there are
just two candidates.
How did you feel about
not having an audience?
-I think it's a positive,
to be honest with you.
I have not been a great fan of
the many debates
that we have had so far.
I think when you're given
75 seconds or 45 seconds
to respond to a question,
often a complicated question
it's very, very difficult
to do that.
I would -- You know, I kin
of think that what a good debate
is about is giving the
candidates the time they nee
to, you know,
go after each other,
discuss their differences
in an amount of time
that allows for
serious discussion.
That has not taken place
up to now.
The last debate, I think,
gave us a little bit more time
I would loosen up
the structure of it a little bit
to allow for more interchange.
-I can say that I also enjoyed
not having an audience
at the last debate, but I do
think they're very vital
to comedy shows.
That's been my experience
this last week.
So I want to ask you this,
which is I think a questio
a lot of people in the
Democratic Party are asking.
Do you still see a path
to the nomination?
Obviously, you're behind
in delegates.
It looks like a very hard path
And, if not, why are you
remaining in the race?
-Well, we're about
300 delegates behind.
Biden has 1,200. We have 900
There is a path.
It is, admittedly,
a narrow path.
But I would tell you, Seth
that there are a lot of people
who are supporting me.
We have a strong
grassroots movement
who believe that
we have got to stay in
in order to continue the fight
to make the world know
that we need Medicare for all,
that we need to raise the
minimum wage to a living wage,
that we need paid
family and medical leave,
one of the crises that
we're dealing with right now
that we must address
climate change and education -
all the issues that
we have been talking about
Campaigns are an important way
to maintain that fight
and raise public consciousness
on those issues.
So that's, I think, one of
the arguments for going forward.
-And do you feel as though
you've had a slight leg up
in the way you've had to
campaign in this digital age
with your early work as a
public-access performer,
your days as a Burlington mayor?
-Well, we have put,
over the years
as a U.S. Senator
and as a candidate,
a whole lot of effort into
social media
and into live streaming.
And we have -- Given the fac
that I can't be out
on the campaign trail,
the rallies, et cetera,
we have been using
our live stream.
And we usually get, you know
sometimes a million,
sometimes 2 million viewers.
So we have put a lot of
resources into that.
We do it pretty well.
And, you know, I think we
do have an advantage
over other folks in that regard.
-Obviously, you're known
for having
an incredibly enthusiastic bas
of supporters.
You're known for having
this incredible outreach -
not just in this campaign,
but the last.
Is it safe to say that if,
for any reason,
you're not the nominee,
that you will try to root
that enthusiasm towards
Joe Biden?
-What I have said, Seth,
from day one, when I announced
that it is absolutely imperative
that we defeat Donald Trump,
who, in my view,
is the most dangerous presiden
in the modern history
of this country.
And we're seeing just
how dangerous he is
with all of the misinformation
that he is providing
during this
coronavirus pandemic.
So, yes, we have got to
defeat Trump,
and if I am not the nominee,
I will do everything I can
to see that Joe Biden
is elected president.
-Well, thank you so much
for being here.
Thank you for
making the time for us.
Stay safe in Burlington,
and hopefully the next tim
I'll see you,
it'll be in the studio.
-Okay. You, too.
Take care. Thanks very much.
-Alright. All the best, Senator.